[Music]
so you're talking Pikachu with no
memories he's addicted to check-in this
is what a Frenchman would call Caliente
fiesta operation this magic that brought
us together
and that magic is called hope use your
body words we're nuts of the games
say it just say it so c'mon detective
Pikachu only in theaters May 10
welcome to Rimes city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me but it's
been so long the tribe talk to me all
the time all they hear is pika pika you
can hear him right you're adorable they
can't understand me kitchen no one else
I don't need a Pokemon period then what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
that brought us together and that magic
is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine yeah tell us what we want to
know pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing
my problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving he's
saying you can shove it what I can shove
it okay that's it no we're switching
roles I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
you